(COUGHS)
BoJack! Well.
Jesus, you look shitty.
Have you been eating your guilt
this whole time?
(ALL LAUGH)
Yeah, you don't look
so hot yourself, Herb.
I have cancer.
And hello.
Who's this stunning creature?
And what string of bad decisions
has placed you
in BoJack's orbit?
-Uh...
-This is Diane.
She's writing a book about me.
Pleasure to meet you.
Is your book called,
Portrait of an Asshole?
(LAUGHS)
I kid. It's funny,
because he ruined my life.
I joke. It's what I do.
Please, come in.
You're letting out
all the cancer.
(LAUGHS)
(FORCED LAUGH)
TODD:
Almost. Ah...
Almost there.
-Ooh! Drive, drive, drive!
-Oh! Oh, no.
-I can't turn the car around.
-(LAUGHS)
-Whoa!
-We've got two sacks
of Kardashian swag
and the fuzz on our heels.
Drive the goddamn car!
(COUGHS)
Hey, Herb, is that your Vitamix?
BoJack has one, too.
I wonder if you guys have
strong opinions about it
one way or the other.
Well, the stupid thing
was like 600 bucks.
I have used mine
a grand total of zero times.
I got it a month
before I was diagnosed
with cancer.
I don't give a shit
about being healthy anymore.
I don't even have cancer,
and I don't use it.
-So who's it for?
-Exactly.
What is so great about liquids?
Every article I read now
is "juice this"
and "juice that."
You know why?
Juice controls the media.
Hey-oh.
(BOTH LAUGH)
Can't this thing go any faster?
Uh, I'm going as fast as I can.
(TIRES SCREECHING)
You're doing a great job.
Kenzie, stop talking to him.
Why? He's being nice.
Remember the number one rule
of the Celebrity Stealing Club--
"No falling in love."
Ugh.
That's your rule for every club.
It's a good rule.
Whoa. Whoa, guys.
I'm sensing
a lot of hostility here.
Maybe we should take
our masks off and actually talk.
You want me to take
my mask off? Fine.
Happy? I took my mask off.
Did you?
Because I think
you're still wearing a mask.
00:02:12,866 --> 00:00:00,000
BOTH:
Oh.